cadeau
tu fasses quoi avec ça il faudrait
qu'ils peppers quitte à vous j'ai
compris
après que woods c'est pour toi c'est
pour venger mois mettre d'accord tu veux
manger tu habitais tous les racistes de
france
si l'info bataille du boulou
on va conquérir le coeur des français et
on va lui faire prendre conscience que
son visage a changé
partant le taquine l'a fait qu'andy a
fait c'est une marche contre le racisme
et pour l'égalité bonjour je vois la
main moi mon fils je connais mieux quoi
c'est une feignasse à bron à rien je
suis sûr qu'il est capable de le faire
ah ouais que capable de faire ça pas
nous allons traverser 55 de parcourir
1200 km
ouais je sais ce n'est pas très nombreux
je suis même tout seul tu marcheras
n'ont pas restitué
non seulement il peut choquer mais n'est
pas thomas de la chance parce que nous
les sentais bien là
et ça comme ça un an malgré tout le
monde
ouais ça dérange les perçoit des amis
ici ou non
aucune loi obligera jamais un homme à
mai mais il est important qu'elle lui
interdise comme linge qu'est ce tu fais
là toi mais je vais marcher à l'évidence
abbatus marché pour le racisme et contre
tous être que vous avez dit l'année une
marque propre et peu sûre plus propre
que toi mais dans la vie il faut savoir
par tous cas on est là pour l'argent est
là pour discuter les mettre aux égalités
roms dans leur pays ces bourreaux qui
risquent rien toi la tête ça gilet pare
balles est-ce qu'on est mieux que toi
racisme va trop loin françois mignard
est membre a cure des gens s'acharnent à
vous arrêter cette marche
je salue la france de toutes les
couleurs nous avons décidé de marcher
est ce que c'est le bon choix on n'en
sait rien mais on on aura essayé